The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Cell potential-- cell
potential delta
E cell, and we're
going to relate this
back to delta G.
So as we saw with these cells,
you have this flow of electrons
through the circuit.
They're generated at the anode
from the oxidation reaction,
and they go over to the cathode.
And when your cell
is running, it'll
generate a potential
difference, this delta E cell,
between those two
electrodes in the cell.
So delta E cell has a
lot of different names.
It's called cell potential, cell
voltage, electron motive force,
EMF.
All of these names are
valid, can be used.
I'm going to try to
call it cell potential.
Hopefully, I'm not
going to switch up.
But if you see
any of these, it's
talking about the same thing.
So overall, then, if we
know this cell potential,
we can relate this
back to delta G.
And so that will then be able to
tell us whether the reaction is
spontaneous or not.
So the overall free energy,
Gibbs free energy, of the cell
is related to the cell potential
by the following equation.
So delta G for the cell
minus n, the number of moles
of electrons that pass
through the system, Faraday's
constant and that
cell potential.
So we can think about
this at a particular time.
We can also think
about this equation
in the standard states.
So let's just think again
about standard states
so we can talk about delta
G0 for the cell and delta
E0 for the cell-- so delta
E0, the cell potential, cell
voltage, EMF for
the cell, in which
the products and the reactants
are in their standard state.
And the unit here is volts.
So we have a new
unit that we haven't
used before, I think-- volts.
So let's look at an example
of how we would then calculate
our delta E0 for a cell.
And we'll do the
cell we've been using
this whole time, our cell
with zinc at anode and copper
at the cathode.
And so we have our
anode reaction.
And again, this is
our oxidation, anox.
And our cathode
reaction, cathred.
So we can write it out as the
reduction reaction happening
at the cathode.
And the equation we're going to
use for this is the following.
So delta E0 of the cell, the
cell potential, equals E0,
and E here is the standard
reduction potential--
and this is the standard
reduction potential
for the couple, the
reaction, that's
happening at the cathode--
minus the standard reduction
potential for the reaction
that's happening at the anode.
So now we can look those
values in the back of the book.
So we have for zinc the
standard reduction potential,
minus 0.7629, and the
standard reduction
potential for the
copper, plus 2 two
electrons to copper solid
reaction, plus 0.3402 volts.
So now clicker
question, why don't you
calculate for me what
the cell potential is
for this type of cell.
So 10 more seconds.
81%, that's right.
So let's take a look
at that over here.
So the correct answer involves
putting the standard reduction
potential for the reaction
at the cathode with the sign,
without changing it
as plus over here,
0.3402, and then it's minus.
And then you put the standard
reduction potential in there,
and this is a minus
value minus, 0.7628.
And minus a minus we get
a plus, and so our answer
is 1.103 volts.
And this is very
important, and it's
important to think
about the reaction
at the cathode, which
is the copper reaction.
The reaction at the anode
is the zinc reaction.
And a lot of people who try
to be too clever with these.
And they're like,
OK, but this one's
the one that's being oxidized,
so I'll switch the sign
and then put it in the equation
and end up getting it wrong.
So if you always remember
standard reduction potential
put here-- standard reduction
potential put here--
the equation already takes
care of the sign issue for you,
so don't do anything
with the sign.
Other people say, I looked
through pages and pages
of these potentials in
the book, and the reaction
I'm looking for isn't
listed, because they're
looking for an oxidation.
They're not going to
find the reaction written
as an oxidation in a table
of reduction potentials.
So all of these are listed
as reduction potentials.
That's what you will find.
The trick is to remember
which is happening
at the cathode, which is
happening at the anode,
and then you will always
get this problem right.
And it's good to get this
right, because as you
will see later on,
this can be step
one in a multi-part problem.
So when we
successfully calculated
delta E of the cell, the cell
potential, then we can ask,
is the flow of electrons going
to be spontaneous for this?
Will it?
It will be.
And the way we know that is
that we can always come back
to delta G. So whenever
you're asked if something
is spontaneous or not, you
always want to think delta G.
That's what I'm going to go for.
I'm going to think
about delta G.
So here delta G equals minus n,
number of moles of electrons,
Faraday's constant, times
that cell potential.
So if the cell
potential is positive,
delta G will be negative.
And is a reaction spontaneous
when delta G is negative?
It's easy to answer.
It's on my shirt today.
I'm giving it all the way-- yes.
So when delta G is
negative, then you
can be feeling spontaneous.
It's a spontaneous reaction.
So delta E positive
means delta G negative.
Reaction is spontaneous.
So now let's have a
little reminder, review,
of what types of cells
have spontaneous reactions
and what kind involve
non-spontaneous reaction.
10 more seconds.
Can anyone tell me
what the correct name
is of the cell that involves
a non-spontaneous reaction?
Electrolytic cell.
So if we look over here-- so
people knew about the galvanic.
That's good.
So a reaction, if it's a
spontaneous reaction that
will produce an
electric current,
that's called a galvanic cell.
If it's a non-spontaneous
reaction that
has to be driven by
applying a current,
that's called an
electrolytic cell.
So I just threw up
another random name
to see if people
would go for it.
So it's important to
keep these in mind,
because a lot of the problems
will say things like,
in this galvanic cell.
And you seem like you don't
have enough information
to solve the problem because
the problem didn't tell you
which reaction was at the
anode or which reaction was
that the cathode.
So how do you do the problem?
Well, the fact they told
you it was a galvanic cell,
there's only one way to
put the reactions in order
for it to be spontaneous.
So that's part of the
problem-- figuring out
which is at the
anode and which is
at the cathode based
on the fact that it has
to be a spontaneous reaction.
So knowing these terms
is really important.
It's hard to do the
problems without them.
Summary of this part, then, so
a cell operate spontaneously.
Whether it does or
not can be determined
by your cell potential.
If it's positive,
it's spontaneous.
And that's because if it's
positive, delta G is negative.
And delta G is really what
tells you about spontaneity.
And you can calculate
your cell potential
from your standard
reduction potentials
that you will find in your book.
So now let's think
about the meaning
of the standard
reduction potential.
What's true if it's a
large positive value?
What's true if it is a
large negative value?
We can look at these
values and know something
about the reactions.
So meaning of standard reduction
potentials-- what do the values
tell us?
So a large positive
standard reduction potential
means that the element
is easy to reduce.
So let's look at an example.
So we have fluorine F2
gas plus two electrons
going 2 fluorine minus ions.
And this has a standard
reduction potential
of plus 2.87 volts.
So large positive
number means that it's
easy to add electrons.
And we can think about
this in terms of what
we know about these reactions.
So again, if it's a positive
standard reduction potential,
E0, that's going to
mean a negative delta
G for this reaction
as written, written
as the reduction reaction.
And so it's favorable or
spontaneous in that direction.
So the reduction is
spontaneous or favorable.
So when you have a large
positive value here,
you can think about, yes,
fluorine wants those electrons.
It spontaneously will grab those
electrons and become F-minus.
And this also makes
sense to you if you
think about your
periodic table trends.
You have fluorine
wants to be F-minus.
It will have its noble
gas configuration then.
It likes getting
an extra electron.
So this should make
sense from other things
that we've talked about.
So now I could ask the question,
and I will, and it's a clicker
question, does that make F2 a
good oxidizing agent or not?
10 more seconds.
So the answer is yes.
F2 is easy to reduce, which
makes it a good oxidizing
agent.
Remember, it's an
agent of oxidation.
It wants to go out there
and oxidize other things.
It wants to itself be reduced.
So something that's a
good oxidizing agent
is easy to reduce.
It wants to be reduced.
It wants to be an
agent of oxidation,
bringing oxidation to the world.
So it's easy to reduce.
It's a good oxidizing agent.
So in general, you can think
about this the following way.
Let's just like bring the
noise down a little bit.
I know it's a clicker
competition day.
So we have a large positive
value here for a reaction.
For a reduction reaction
is written large positive
standard reduction potential.
And the couple
here, F2 to F-minus
is the couple we're
talking about.
And we'll say that the
oxidized species of that couple
is very oxidizing.
And again, F2 here is
the oxidized species.
So the oxidized species F2
is a good oxidizing agent.
It's very oxidizing because
it has a large positive
standard reduction potential.
So I don't know how
well this copied.
But here are some standard
reduction potentials.
They're all in your book, so
it's OK if they look terrible.
But the important point
here is that the top.
We have large positive values.
So if you can see
that in your handout,
this is the reaction
we just talked about,
or the couple we just talked
about-- F2 F-minus and so
large positive.
And then there's a gap here.
There are pages
and pages and pages
of these standard
reduction potentials.
And at the very bottom, you
have a large negative number,
so large positive on the top
large, negative on the bottom.
So at the very top, the
oxidized species of that couple
is very oxidizing.
And we'll see it in a
minute, that at the bottom
the reduced species, when
it's a negative number here,
the reduced species
is very reducing.
So let's look at
the reduced species,
and this is lithium
on the bottom.
So a large negative
standard reduction potential
means that the element
is hard to reduce.
So example, lithium
plus 1 plus 1 electron
going to lithium solid.
The standard reduction
potential for this reaction
is minus 3.045 volts.
So it's hard to add
electrons to lithium-plus.
We have a negative standard
reduction potential,
which means a positive
delta G for the reaction
is written for the
reduction reaction.
So it's not favorable.
Lithium-plus does
not want electrons.
It doesn't want to
go to lithium solid.
So lithium-plus, if
it loses an electron,
it gets its nice noble
gas configuration.
It's a group-one element.
It likes to be in the
plus-1 oxidation state.
It doesn't want to be reduced.
So is lithium plus 1 a
good oxidizing agent?
No, it's not.
It does not want to be reduced.
But lithium solid is
a good reducing agent.
It's a good reducing
agent because it
wants to reduce other things.
It wants to itself
become oxidized.
So lithium solid will
reduce other things.
Lithium solid wants
to be oxidized.
It wants to be lithium plus 1.
So the rule here for those
large, negative standard
reduction potential
couples is that
with a large negative
standard reduction
potential, the reduced
species is very reducing.
The reduced species
here is lithium.
So lithium is reduced
compared to lithium plus 1.
This, then, is very reducing.
It is a good reducing agent.
Do you think lithium plus 1
would be a good reducing agent?
What do you think?
So if it was a good
reducing agent,
it wants to reduce other
things and become oxidized.
Do you think lithium
plus 2 is a good thing?
No.
So again, in this couple,
it's the reduced species
that's very reducing.
And so you have to think
about this a little bit.
Make sure that you
pick the right one.
Often you'll ask
about rank the order
of these as reducing agents.
And people remember
this, but don't
remember which
species of the couple
is going to be doing the thing.
So think about what's happening.
Lithium solid, does it want
to become lithium plus 1?
It sure does.
Does lithium plus 1 want
to become lithium plus 2?
No.
So again, back to
just our table just
for a second, on the top-- large
positive, oxidized species very
oxidizing, negative value,
reduced species very reducing.
And now if we look
at this, I don't
know how well this came
out in your handout
either, but part of
the periodic table
for you kind of compressed.
Over here we have fluorine,
large positive, standard
reduction potential,
easy to reduce over here,
good oxidizing agents.
If they get an electron,
if they're reduced,
they get their noble
gas configuration.
Over here, we have these
big negative numbers,
easy to oxidize the solid or
the neutral to their plus 1.
So they would be
good reducing agents.
And so this all makes sense
when you think about trends
in the periodic table.
So today we're going to have
two examples of why all of this
is important across disciplines.
So often these units
are really talked--
you talk about making
batteries and things like that.
And that is important.
In fact, with
energy initiatives,
making batteries is a
really hot area right now.
But all these things
you're learning
are also related to biology
and to medicine as well.
And so we have one more of the
"In Their Own Words" segment.
And John Essigmann studies DNA
damage as related to cancer.
And people are like, what
is DNA damage and cancer
have to do with oxidation
reduction potentials?
But it's not all about
oxidation reduction.
That's what a lot
of the damage is.
So why don't you hear
from John Essigmann.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- My name's John Essigmann.
I'm in the Department
of Chemistry
and Biological Engineering MIT.
I'm a toxicologist by training,
so I study how cells respond
to toxins, and in particular,
the kinds of toxins
that cause nucleic acid damage.
Some of these are chemicals
from out in the environment,
organic compounds,
that cause DNA damage.
But I'm also interested in
how chemicals inside our body,
for example, reactive
forms of oxygen,
the molecule that we breathe,
also cause nucleic acid damage.
Oxidation is the
process by which
we convert our metabolic
fuels into energy.
This is a gummy bear being
oxidized by potassium chlorate.
This is exactly the kind
of chemical reaction
that goes on in your bodies.
But in your body, it goes
on at a much lower rate.
Oxygen is a double-edged sword.
There are two aspects to
its use that is good for us.
The first one is by acting
as an electron acceptor,
sort of like an
anode in a battery,
it completes the
circuit and allows
us to be able to generate
free energy that we can
use to power vital processes.
That's good.
The second good thing is
that it's the ammunition
of our innate immune system.
[COUGHING]
Oxygen is used to
charge the system
to produce one, two, or three
electron-reduced species
that themselves can react
with reactive nitrogen species
to create a host of
very damaging oxidants.
Our innate immune system
uses these to protect us
against invaders
and oftentimes, we
believe, developing
cancer cells.
The bad thing is that the
second system I described
doesn't have a lot
of accuracy in how it
focuses that chemical warfare.
So not only are the,
let's say, invading
bacterial cells or
the cancer cells hit,
but surrounding cells as well.
And that creates
oxidative damage
in the genomes of those cells,
those innocent bystanders.
If those cells divide, the
oxidative damage that's in them
can cause mutations, and that
sets the cell along a path.
If you accumulate enough
mutations in enough genes,
you're going to convert
that normal cell
into a cancer cell that
will grow out into a tumor.
[END PLAYBACK]
CATHERINE DRENNAN: So
that was one of, I think,
the only video, besides mine,
that involved a faculty member.
But I thought it's
nice to have a sort
of a collection of
different folks talking
about their research.
And this relates to
free radical species
as well as to oxidation
and reduction.
So now I have another bio
example, which hopefully we'll
get to at the end.
But I want to introduce
a very important equation
for this unit and
oxidation reduction, which
is the Nernst equation.
So here, and this happens,
I think, to all of us
all the time-- our
exhausted batteries.
So when you have
a battery or you
go to turn on your headphones
or use your laser pointer
or things like that and the
battery doesn't work anymore,
it's because the cell reaction
has reached equilibrium.
So equilibrium is a
state of calmness.
It's also a state of
batteries not working anymore.
And so at this point,
when it's at equilibrium,
the cell generates
zero potential
across its electrodes.
It's not working anymore.
It is a dead battery.
And we need to think about
when it reaches equilibrium,
what state it's in at
any given time compared
to its equilibrium state.
So this really brings us
back to some of the ideas
that we had in the
chemical equilibrium unit,
where we were thinking about
composition of a reaction
at any given time compared
to the equilibrium state.
So how does cell potential
change with cell composition?
So again, we know
a lot about this.
And exam three on Friday
has equilibrium on it.
So we already know a lot about
what happens in relationships
between equilibrium.
And we know that delta G
changes as the composition
changes in the cell.
And until equilibrium
is reached-- so again,
reactions going forward
and back in equilibrium--
the forward direction equals
the reverse direction.
But at some given time that
is not always the case.
So the equation that
we know from before is
that delta G equals delta
G0 plus RT natural log of Q.
And so if you know
delta G and Q,
you can talk about what
the delta G is going
to be at a particular
composition of the cell
with a particular
value of Q. So now we
can think, well, OK, here's what
we know about Q, that reaction
quotient, and delta G.
What do we know about delta
G and E, the cell potential?
And we just talked about that.
So we know that delta
G0 equals minus n,
the number of
moles of electrons,
Faraday's constant times
that cell potential.
So now we can do a
rearrangement of terms.
We can combine and come up
with the Nernst equation.
So here are the two equations.
One we knew before.
One we just learned about today.
And we can put those together.
We can plug in for delta
G here without the 0,
and for delta G0
with the 0 over here.
And then we can
divide both sides
by minus the number
of moles of electrons
and Faraday's constant, come
up with the Nernst equation.
So the Nernst equation
compares our cell potential
under standard conditions
with our cell potential
at any given time based on
that reaction quotient Q.
So let's do an example
with the Nernst equation.
So let's calculate the cell
potential at a particular time
when the zinc plus 2 ions are
0.1 and copper plus 2 is 0.0010
molar.
And we're same cell
as we've done before.
So step one, very easy, we want
to calculate the cell potential
under standard conditions.
And this is particularly
easy because we already
did this today.
So you already told me
it's plus 1.103 volts.
So we could look up our
standard reduction potentials
for our copper couple and our
zinc couple and calculate this.
So we already did
this, and that's
why I said you want to make
sure you get this right
because it's often just step
one of a multi-part problem.
So we want to get that right.
Step two is calculating Q, and
this is a clicker question.
10 more seconds.
I tried to make the
math not that hard.
So Q, products over reactants,
so one thing you want to do
is make sure you have the
reaction written correctly.
So you know what the products
are and what the reactants are.
And here we have the
zinc ions over copper.
Copper solid and
zinc solid don't
appear in the
equilibrium expression
or in the Q expression
also because they're solids
and their concentration
is not changing.
So there is enough
information that
was given because we
don't include the solids.
So it's just the
concentration of zinc ions
over the concentration of copper
ions, or 1.0 times 10 to the 2.
Now we need to know n.
So n is the number of
moles of electrons that
are involved in this reaction.
This reaction involves
how many electrons?
How many?
It involves two, right.
So the zinc to zinc plus
2, copper plus 2 to copper,
so it involves two electrons.
So this is two, and sometimes
you can just look at this
and realize it's two
electrons involved.
Other times you have
to balance the reaction
to figure out how many
electrons are involved.
It's not obvious by
looking at the reaction.
This is a simple one,
but some of them are not.
So that's we're balancing
reactions comes in handy.
so
Now we have everything
we need to plug it
into the Nernst equation.
So we can put it in.
We calculated this
standard cell potential
over here, the plus 1.1 value.
We can look up R. Everything,
again, room temperature.
Natural log of Q,
we calculated Q.
We have two electrons
and Faraday's constant.
And we can multiply this
out, get this value.
In terms of significant figures,
this also is a lot of fun.
We have log rules of significant
figures, multiplication
and division rules of
significant figures,
and adding and subtracting
rules of significant figures,
and also in terms of units.
All of a sudden, volts appeared.
That was nice because our
answer should be in volts.
But where did they come from?
So we had our kelvins
are going to cancel out.
But we have joules over here.
And we have coulombs.
But luckily, a joule per
coulomb equals a volt.
So we're all set to get
our appropriate units.
So just a couple of things
that I'll mention about this as
well-- sine almost
all these problems are
at room temperature, I
try to make your lives
a little bit easier on the
exam and multiply this out
for you, because these
are all constants,
and they're big
constants that involve
plugging a lot of numbers in.
So I will give you
this combined value.
And if you use log
instead of natural log,
you need to change
that value here.
And so what I actually
put on equation sheets
are these equations.
I'll also put the full
equation there as well but just
to make your lives
a little bit easier.
It's horrible to make
mistakes up there.
So just briefly, what about at
equilibrium, what does Q equal?
Q equals K. Delta G equals 0.
And so we can rewrite
this expression again,
which we've done before.
And if we take this and
look at this expression now,
we can again combine
these-- we have
two expressions for delta G0--
and combine them and solve.
And you can see
that you can also
calculate K from standard
reduction potentials.
So all the things that we
have been learning here,
we can always come back
to chemical equilibrium.
So I'm done with everything
but my second bio example.
So you'll have to
wait until next week
to find out how vitamin B12
gets reduced in the body.
Let's just take 10 more seconds
on the clicker question.
Does someone want a
nice T-shirt to tell me
how they got the right answer?
Pass this back.
AUDIENCE: So when you're
looking at the Pb--
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Let's all quiet down.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] and
zinc, zinc is going to reduce--
CATHERINE DRENNAN:
Let's quiet down.
AUDIENCE: --Pb because it
goes from a 2 plus charge
to no charge at all.
So that's reducing its charge.
And then in the
reverse reaction,
Pb does the same
thing to zinc 2 plus
and takes it from 2 plus
to a neutral charge.
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yep, great.
So the trick to this is
just look at the equations
and figure out what
is being oxidized
and what is being reduced
in both directions.
Oxidation reduction, it's
not just about batteries.
Batteries, of course,
are very important.
There's a lot of active
research right now
in trying to make better
batteries that are more
environmentally friendly, just
solving the energy problem
every single possible way.
But even if you're not
interested in solving
the energy problem,
oxidation reduction
is really important in medicine.
So I'm just going to give you
another bio example for this.
So there's a vitamin in
your body, vitamin B12
It has one of the largest
negative reduction potentials
of any biological molecule.
So we ask the question,
how can something like that
be reduced in the body?
So let me introduce
you to vitamin B12.
You're going to see this
a couple of times today.
So vitamin B12 needs to
be reduced to be active.
But it has a low
reduction potential.
This is the vitamin
B12, and you'll
see several more
views of it, and it's
in pictures in your
handout of today's lecture.
There's an enzyme that requires
vitamin B12 and another B
vitamin called folic acid.
And if this enzyme is
not functioning properly
in your body, it leads
to all sorts of things.
It's connected to heart disease.
If women don't have enough folic
acid while they're pregnant,
it can lead to birth
defects, neural tube disease,
where the brain
doesn't form properly.
Also, there is rising evidence
connecting a vitamin B12
deficiency with bringing
on Alzheimer's disease.
And some people actually buy
little B12 squirt bottles
and squirt it into
their nose before exams.
I'm not sure that helps.
But as you get older,
I would seriously
consider taking
extra vitamin B12.
So since we're
talking about this,
we'll have a little
nutrition quiz.
Where do you get vitamin B12
and folic acid in your diet?
First let's think
about vitamin B12.
Does anyone know where you get
this, besides vitamin pills,
in food?
Where do you get vitamin
B12 in food, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Broccoli?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Broccoli, no.
We had a hand up there.
Anyone else?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Meat?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Meat,
yes-- red meat, actually
any kind of meat.
But hardly ever is
red meat the answer
to a nutritional question.
So I thought I'd put it up
there in big bold red letters.
Yeah, you get B12 in meat.
Plants don't use vitamin B12.
So you can eat as many
plants as you want.
Unless they're covered with
bacteria that do use B12,
you will not get
any in your diet.
So if you're vegetarian, you
should take a vitamin tablet.
You don't need much, so it's
not really your problem.
But it does come from red meat.
What about folic acid?
Any guesses where
folic acid comes from?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Broccoli?
CATHERINE DRENNAN: Yes.
Very good.
So it's the fall in New England,
and hopefully some of you
have gone out and
seen the foliage.
So folic acid does come
from green leafy things.
And if you're Norwegian, you
will also say the following.
So Norwegian scientists claim
that the great longevity
of Norwegians has
to do with the fact
that their beer is
rich in folic acid.
And somehow they
even got a grant
from the Norwegian government
to study the correlation
between beer and health.
Everyone signed up for
that study, I'm sure.
So red meat and beer
for good health.
But yes, leafy green
vegetables, yes, folic acid,
foliage, also orange
juice is really high.
And at one point, they had this
commercial for orange juice.
It's not just for
breakfast anymore.
It's good for your heart.
Well, that was because of
the folic acid in there.
And that's actually true.
So there was a commercial
that actually provided you
with valuable
nutritional advice.
Not so sure about
the beer, but I'd
go buy the leafy greens
and the orange juice.
So you need both of
these to be healthy.
But again, we have this
problem that vitamin B12
has this low negative
redox potential.
So how is it reduced?
Well, in the body it's
reduced by a protein called
flavodoxin, which has a flavon,
which is another B vitamin.
So there's lots of B
vitamins going on here.
So the standard reduction
potential for vitamin B12
is minus 0.526.
That's a really low
number for biology.
And for flavodoxin,
it's minus 0.23.
So we ask, which is the
better reducing agent?
And that's the clicker question.
Let's just do 10 more seconds.
Yep.
So the better reducing agent
wants to reduce other things
and get oxidized itself.
So vitamin B12, with its
low negative potential,
is very reducing.
It wants to reduce other things.
It wants to be an
agent of reduction.
But that's not what's
supposed to happen.
It's not supposed to
reduce flavodoxin.
It's supposed to happen
the other way around.
So we could ask, is
the reduction, then,
of vitamin B13 by
flavodoxin spontaneous
if this is the case, yes or no?
No.
It shouldn't be spontaneous.
It's not going the
way that it should go.
So we can just calculate how
exactly non-spontaneous it is.
So we can calculate both
what the change in potential
is, and we can also
calculate delta G0 from this.
So we saw how to do this before.
But we were talking
about different kinds
of galvanic or
electrolytic cells.
But now we can use
the same equation
that we saw before but
talk about it in terms
of a biological system.
So before we saw to calculate
E0 of the cell, the cell
potential, we had the
standard reduction potential
for the couple at the anode
minus the standard reduction
potential for a
couple at the cathode.
We can do the same
thing here but just
put reduction and
oxidation over here.
So we can make this
a generic equation.
And we can plug our values in.
So the thing being
reduced is vitamin B12.
So we want to put the reduction
potential of B12 in there.
And the thing being
oxidized is the flavodoxin.
And so minus
0.526six for the B12.
Standard reduction
potential would
be 12 minus the
standard reduction
potential of flavodoxin.
And we get a negative
number, minus 0.0296 volts.
So then we have
a negative value,
which should tell us that delta
G is going to be positive.
But we can also
calculate that value
from the equation
you saw before.
So just because we are talking
about these equations in terms
of cells before,
we can also talk
about it's same exact equation
that we use in biology.
So minus n, number of
moles of electrons--
this is a one-electron process.
I would have had
to tell you that.
You wouldn't necessarily
have known it's one electron.
But that's our one.
What is this term here, this
kind of weird-looking F term?
What is that again?
Faraday's constant.
Then we plug in
our cell potential
or potential difference.
And we get out a value
positive 28.6 kilojoules
per mole-- big positive number.
So is this spontaneous?
Why don't we all
have heart disease?
It is not a
spontaneous reaction.
So how is it driven forward ?
This happens in our body.
This reaction happens.
So clearly something has to
happen to make it spontaneous.
So when we were talking about
the different kinds of cells,
we had electrolytic cell,
where we could put in a current
to drive a
non-spontaneous reaction.
Same thing happens in
biology, and the current
in this particular
case is a molecule
known as adenosylmethionine.
So it's the methionine amino
acid within a denosyl group
attached to it.
And the cleavage of this
molecule is very spontaneous.
It has a delta G of minus
30.6 kilojoules, which
is greater than what we need.
And we can even
calculate the net delta G
for this reaction,
the coupled reaction,
of the cleavage
with the reduction.
And if we do that, we have
minus 37.6 plus 28.6, so
minus 9.0 kilojoules per mole.
So we can drive this
unfavorable reduction reaction
with a very favorable
reaction, the cleavage
of adenosylmethionine.
And that's how it works.
So that's why we're all healthy.
So this is the end of our
oxidation reduction example.
We'll transition to
transition metals.
But we're not moving very far
away from oxidation reduction.
Because to do problems that are
effective transition metals,
you have to know how to
determine oxidation numbers
and all sorts of things.